hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Breanna
white Breanna why tonight today are
gonna check out the Friday the 13th a
game official announcement trailer
I like the Friday the 13th movie series
for the most part and Breanna is such a
big fan of horror loves horror as a
matter of fact if you end up dating her
just take her to a horror movie and
she'll love you everything he said was
false see I know her dad watches this
channel every now and again so I got to
watch my jokes a little bit more but
trust me there's someone this noggin I
don't think after the last video he'll
ever tune in again
oh so make as many jokes as I want let's
good let's continue this video late
stage no stop PlayStation I don't know
where it is you know what it's called
man we're in for it
the thought is this over after it
happened I expected someone to do
something I expected parents to show up
with questions and concerns I thought
the police would have done more but
nothing happened nothing changed quiet
here they opened it again next year
and they were back to their old habits
Troy did you hear something
relax me probably just keep trying to
scare us they're just kids
right Susie he was just an innocent boy
I was a good mother to him my boy my
sweet sweet Jason
interesting I really don't know how I
feel about I don't either the fact that
it was narrated by his mom for one well
that's how the first Friday 13 shows
down is you know it's like oh it's the
mom it's a big reveal
sorry ruin that for you guys but that's
why I know they're like trying to get
funny for this like they're talking
about you know unleash Jason only on
Kickstarter as far as what I'm seeing
right now I feel like they're trying to
capture the tone and style of Friday the
13th but it's just coming across extra
cheesy
although yeah I don't want to be a
little candy yeah I mean can't be works
cuz it's Friday the 13th
exactly it works I just don't get what
the gameplay would necessarily be that's
a good point my god I don't quite
understand either I did an explorer game
or a strategy game are you playing as
Jason are you running away from Jason
like what is the actual storyline to
this particular Friday 13th game I want
I want to see some gameplay footage what
they have in development that might
really piqued my interest a lot cuz so
far the cinematic effects are not the
greatest you know like that's my biggest
problem when I see like a video game
that's adapted from a movie is you're
like a lot of the time you're like ah
the graphics don't look that good
because I don't know they feel like kind
of cheesy graphics to me but well my
biggest problem with this trailer is
that you know it wasn't that scary or
anything
it just was kind of a lackluster trailer
in my opinion yeah there's no there's no
emotional graviton right that happened
here I was like okay it's starting a
creepy trying to get creepy and now it's
over and you know I didn't even really
jump out and scare you it was kind of a
very subtle like reveal I felt like yeah
you know I mean I gotta admit they'll be
because it's Friday the 13th I am
interested to see what game they have in
mind
so gameplay footage I feel like if that
looks rewarding I feel like it really
win me over well we're really
intellectual mm-hmm you feel that you
feel the intellect you feel that I'm
more than just looks
she's just brains yeah I'm um you know
like people are always like Ryan you're
just good-looking you have no talent you
don't really have opinions he wants
people to know there's more to him
there's more to me than just this
gorgeous smile in mind me you deserve
better
I deserve so much more well anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe today
and become a reject inator and get your
gaming on with sibling rivalry Breanna
White's gaming channel with her and her
broseph it's a fun channel it's fun and
me get a look at her hear her listen to
her absorb her and then you know you're
alone at home on your computer who knows
what you're doing see that's a little
more subtle what can what am i implying
what am i no one knows no one really
knows yeah to absorb and you're alone of
your computer watch ok and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine and periscope let's do a shadow
Michael Woodall ah Woodall he's all wood
ah your videos are the best and love
everybody that you bring onto your vids
can I please get a shout out
Michael Woodall um let me tell you man
you probably got wood right now from
watching this video I mean it's me
nothing to do with this o0 I know oh I
can't even look into a mirror anymore
that's you how can you they always crack
can I can't even own them you should be
embarrassed honey so many money's mine
even Michael Woodall was like I want to
get some wood on the real rejects comes
here sees you gosh ruins it ruins every
I'm sorry Michael now he has to go look
at me with his wood well that's what he
wanted in the first place yeah I did
everyone wants that's what everyone
wanted on't come for the chicks they
come for me ah they come what was that
that was my overemphasized wink
oh you winked i winked all I saw was her
mouth open I was like what did she just
play along with the joke